do employers look for creative people no
not generally there's increasing demand
in corporations for creative people but
the problem with being creative is that
you're useless at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy you're not there to
think outside the box you're there to
learn what you're supposed to do and
implement it and creative people that is
what they do what happens though to
companies is that because they filter
all the creative people out at the
bottom and then people start to rise up
to the top you really need creative
people at the top because they are the
entrepreneurial types and they're the
ones for example in law firms the more
entrepreneurial ones are the ones that
bring in all the business but it's also
very difficult to nurse them within any
system because systems do not nurture
creativity the artist is always the
person who stands outside the structure
or maybe builds his or her own structure
which is also why it's hard to evaluate
creative people you can't if they're
operating within the confines of a
system that has an evaluative structure
they're not creative